[Music]
good morning miss garcia
good morning sunshine i miss you i could
kiss you right now
sunday
tensions rise as we enter the 213th week
of lockdown
grim new reality emerges over
[Music]
new data confirms the virus attacks the
brain tissue
all infected americans are being forced
into quarantine camps
sarah every little thing sir what's
going on
department of sanitation sarah talk to
me i think my neighbor has a fever it'll
be so much easier if you just open the
door
mrs grant you have visitors
sarah do not open that door
beginning thermal scan three two
one anomaly detected
armed guards will be arriving in four to
six hours
you must not attempt to leave your home
or you will be shot on site
[Applause]
i know you're in there
[Applause]
sarah i'm not letting you give up
we have to do things we don't want
to survive i'm trying to save the one
person left
in my life that matters to me
i can't help you what you're talking
about is illegal
come here
gonna be all right and remember stay
safe
save and sanitize
that was a terrible crash
we're lucky to be alive
who are you
it's so loud here we call it the noise
happened to all the men on this planet
every thought in our heads
we're on display
where are all the women
they're dead
[Music]
why is she thinking where the hell is
her noise it's strange to see everything
you're thinking no it's strange for me
too not knowing what's going on in your
head
i mean i know you might not like my dog
or you want to hit me over the head with
a rock or something
i like your dog he's stronger than he
knows
if you want to protect the girls you
have to leave now
with her power there's no telling what
he can do
i need that girl before she wants them
how many are coming 100
200 thousands
[Music]
be quiet
[Music]
after a lifetime of being the world's
most famous enemies you can't count
[Music]
in the big city
this hotel has been host to four
presidents three popes two kings
and we're about to host the wedding of
the century do you think you're
qualified to take on this position i
shine under pressure like a diamond
or rihanna one other thing
we have a mouse problem with the what
now i'll catch it sir
everybody
[Music]
oh wow this is so detailed
we could hire an exterminator or we can
leverage
millions of years of predatory evolution
if a picture of this mouse is tweeted
out to insta book face or tiki talk
we will be ruined no sir that's not
gonna happen
that rodent is toast
i will not let this hotel be ruined by a
cat and a mouth
he's dying on us
i think i might have just pulled this
off
oh
[Music]
that david played and please the lord
but you don't really care
for music do you
it goes like this
hallelujah
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i did my best it wasn't much
i couldn't feel so i tried to touch
i've told the truth
[Music]
hallelujah
[Music]
hi hey
[Music]
this guy's probably fought hundreds of
thousands of other super beings on the
other planets he's destroyed right and
we have to assume he's one i don't care
how many demons he's fought and how many
hells
he's never fought us not us united
there's something cursed about this land
our family moved west on a promise
a promise that now looked rotten
there's no room for boys in this family
anymore
and no one warned my brother about what
can happen when you dream about destiny
that's how alison wells
entered this story
[Music]
the thief and murderer allison wells
sent five human souls to heaven if you
see this woman
do not confront her
okay
somebody's gonna pay me twenty thousand
to get them to mexico you even imagine
that much money we gotta get all the
farmers and we gotta search
i need to get out of here you're hunting
me
you found her ain't ya who was lady
it's complicated you know the worst part
of dying is king
is being forgotten
[Music]
it's not safe me being here
or for any of us for that matter
i won't be another victim of their lives
scared ass
yeah me too
[Music]
[Music]
this is eleanor the motherland's
youngest trainee
all she wanted was to be a real fairy
godmother
recite it with me please a glittery gown
turns around upside down
i know that i can do this i'm going to
prove that people still
need fairy godmothers i'm looking for
mackenzie walsh let's see what we can
find
siri search mackenzie walsh okay
here's what i found who said that is
there a genie in there
don't answer that i'm looking for a sad
little girl named mackenzie walsh
that is me no it can't be you you're
old have you seen yourself security
me again i'm your fairy godmother back
off lady morning
oh good you're awake too is this your
true love
not anymore life isn't always a fairy
tale i came all this way to help you
find your heart's desire you know what
you need
the makeover what what have you done to
my eyebrows
magic my house i know right
you turn my dog into a pig this belt got
away from me
oh it's okay he's just here to help with
the housework
i know you want to help her
life isn't as simple as happily ever
after fine after all nine out of ten
fairy tales begin with once upon a time
something amazing happened while she was
drinking wine in her sweatpants
i've been trapped in the fairy tale when
the real world is full of so much more
you're starting to believe in magic
aren't you
[Music]
are you sure i can't make you a ball
gown before i go hey please wait no
please
[Music]
nice dress is it new don't be mad don't
you mad
[Applause]
me
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
oh god
foreign
technology it's always watching us
studying our every move and it just
focused its attention
on carol peters thanks so much for being
here carol what is this
let's jump right into it i don't like
this why is it doing that
i'm gonna find out who you are okay
carol i am a technological super
intelligence
i can control every dollar and every
machine on the planet
i know that voice is this james corden
i'm not james corden carol my analysis
showed that hearing james corden's voice
would calm you
you sent an email to james corden
claiming to be the president of corden's
wardens that was a tough night for me oh
boy
i plan on spending these next three days
hanging out with you why
you you're literally the most average
person on earth
oh ooh you okay yep just really engage
your core
oh that was worse huh
[Music]
what would you do if i told you the
world was going to end in three days try
to make things right with george
harold you look amazing weirdly
overdressed
your body i'm just getting a little bit
panicky because i can't access my own
hand
what does the ai want my intention is to
solidify my theory about humanity
if things don't go well i'll destroy the
planet just blow it up
did you say blow up like b like like
boba
or bert bacharach yes bbb oh my god
i'm going to show you that people are
worth saving humans are more complex
than i thought
we're all counting on you there's any
indication that it's aware of what we're
doing
click this might save the world don't
click it now i wasn't going to click it
now
okay why would i click it now you just
said it looks like a pen people click
pens nervously okay are we done
this is nice these are nice people it's
not like a russian mob but a nice change
of pace
then i guess on the other hand this
thing could destroy the earth
wrong no no it's too bad
[Music]
we are entering dangerous territory
the enemy has moment
protecting innocent lives is our duties
[Music]
oh
oh here we are i bet this brings back
some fond memories huh
[Music]
last time i was here i was getting
wheeled out on a stretcher
not that memory throughout history
humans have had a primal instinct to
compete
to dominate and through these battles an
unexpected camaraderie was born
this is a story about my group of
friends
all right boys here we go the buddy
games are back we're gonna play for a
150
000 bucks we'll play your high stakes
[ __ ] but that was not easy to scrape up
i gave obama a hand job for 30 dollars
i'm giving you the early bird special oh
expand on that no i'm not going to you
want to smell my hand no no
probably not kicking off this year's
event
get a girl to buy you a drink got it
easy enough you can do that without
[ __ ] your pants first
relaxing this man oh
hey can you buy me a drink i live in my
van what no
i'll try your box for a week you like
vodka
yeah two wet ones
[Music]
is it injured because it doesn't feel
[Music]
good
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you're gonna wipe my ass
enter the dragon what
he sensed his fear
that was intense
god damn dude
[Music]
well how was camp any good digs yeah
some
we're here hey
[Music]
this is my boyfriend john it's a
pleasure to finally meet you
i hope you don't mind that i'm here i
know it's your lake house and i'm not
trying to take away time with your mom
it's important to me that you're okay
with this i'm happy for you guys
[Music]
[Applause]
how did you guys meet i've been at the
lake all year studying a few species
here
you're kind of a weird dude i guess i am
but i mean weird is cool right
do you always lock the doors when you
sleepwalk i saw you
walk into the lake towards his light i'm
pretty dry
i love him so so much
we're gonna be a family we have to learn
how to forgive
and forget right lips
get off of him
he's here
nice pad richard you haven't changed it
on bruce
you might be surprised
what was that back there a mess it's a
way to keep my lives
separate i can't think of the last time
we saw each other
i bet you can remember the last time the
first time too
i'm eager to learn they all say that ben
turner richard dragon
shiva disciplined honorable
she's very dedicated
ben shiva i assume you're in some kind
of trouble
the cobra cult a worldwide organization
of murderous zealots
kill them we have to stop it no matter
what
i ain't ever gonna turn down whooping
somebody's ass
no matter how much you train evil
remains
we're not done yet again
a quarry is a bit more formidable than
we thought
that's handy this isn't going to be easy
[Music]
remember you are stronger together than
[Music]
apart
you brothers you could move mountains
without lifting a finger
minister malcolm x good news the chariot
is coming
who's mcgregor that's right jim brown
takes the ball your record is going to
stand the test of time
all together
the entire city of miami is celebrating
i'm the new heavyweight champion of the
world and i don't even have a scratch on
my face
oh my goodness okay why am i so pretty
hey congratulations jim i can get used
to that
i was made in america
this movement that we are in is called a
struggle
because we are fighting for our lives
this ain't about civil rights they ain't
giving black people what they really
want
what's that hey i was made in america
that's why i'm out here
power black power i like the sound of
that
i wish i lived in america we have to be
there for each other everybody rich all
i gotta do is
can you hear me
[Music]
okay then who wants the first dance
max cloud is here
uh dad playing those damn games
all day every day
okay so keep it together is this real
can i touch you
pull yourself together soldier we don't
have time for this
what beer is not near cowboy is
here i'm pretty sure i'm in the game
i'm kind of freaking out right now sarah
look out
good work soldier that's a true violence
can you hear me shouting
literally no one was shouting
[Music]
the game you might actually have a
chance of getting out of here
the fate of the universe lies in the
hands of max
cloud did i say the universe again you
were fantastic
what does sacrifice mean to you means
being selfless
committed now our tradition here
is unlike any other
we're family
now ray these scholarships are yearly
you perform on the field you perform in
the classroom
and if you don't they take that all away
yes coach
[Music]
there's no guaranteed spot on my team
it's my brother
again faymar
ray earlier this morning i got her into
a 30-day inpatient program
we'll be placing feymar in foster care
can't i just have a family number
watch me it's cool you should be getting
back to school anyway i'll be good
something in me is awakening
uh-huh wait
i'll take them all then they say it's
day praying that i wouldn't make it i
had to bring my little brother to live
with me on campus we should look inside
find a motivation
may we build bridges and break limits
mom's going
it's just doing me trying to make a
better way when the day's finished you
don't have to do this on your own
for the future
i just want to leave a page in it why
are you helping me
everyone's family
my here and i had it kind of tough
growing up
[Music]
clemson has given me the opportunity to
change my life
my coaches my teammates
these men are my brothers too history in
the making
you've been waiting for this your whole
life
[Music]
was the night before life day in a
galaxy far
far away looking good tree food
decorations all coming together heroes
were
to celebrate the day please be okay
please be a cape
that's a wrap for ray adventure called
and she thought it would be fast but
there
she found a key to the galaxy's past
what are you doing this is so cool we've
seen my master
my master's master concentrate my
master's father impressive
my master's father's master dipper or
palpatine i don't believe it uh
you think maybe you could put a shirt on
it's a key
to travel for space and time i will
change to the future
so sure are you less talky talky more
fighty fighting
oh so cute
you thinking what i'm thinking music
a time of joy this is ray a friendship
a family
who are you guys master skywalker my son
i mean my these binary sons
you want to shoot first after you
[Music]
how's she doing she barely speaks to me
i don't need your sympathy uncle john
that mustang's got a real mean streak
she's just angry
she was rounded up and taken away from
her family
what's her name i haven't given her a
name yet
[Music]
i heard you lost your family too
you really are beautiful
that's what i'll call you black beauty
you've gotten closer to that philly in
days than i have in weeks
they say horses pick you
the rescues have a time limit you can't
sell me
you're my family you know that right
watch it go watch it go better
[Music]
if i fought for every horse i'd ever
loved out of 100 of them
i don't want 100 horses i just want one
[Music]
you